[Music]
think you should branch out make some
new friends
you never know what happened Janel
Parrish giving out dating advice in her
new film to all the boys I've loved
before it's about time mana deserve some
love too and dishing the relationship
dirt on her Pretty Little Liars
character Moana in the upcoming spinoff
everyone is so excited that we're gonna
keep this PLL up going with the
profession yeah and Mona's gonna have a
love interest Marlene told us you have
to look at the big picture Mike we saw
her with two relationships I really
liked the Mona and Mike relationship but
since then she hasn't really had love in
her life and I think it's nice to see
that romantic side of her kind of get
brought out you know as you know Mona
has a lot of different sides and it's
kind of fun to see her romantic side so
I'm ready Mona I brought pie I think
it's gonna be Mona's type how would you
describe her type in the perfectionist I
don't know we're kind of seeing a
different Mona at the very beginning of
this new show we're seeing a little bit
more humbled Mona so I'd like to see her
with somebody like Mike who's who's
loving and kind but I also think she
likes the bad boys too you know like an
old con so I'm kind of down for a love
triangle I think they'd be fun drama pol
first a also dished on her mini faces on
the hit show do you have any beauty
regrets from pol I kind of loved all the
sides of Mona I kind of liked that she
was dramatic and had lots of makeup on
and like did the whole curl like she
went through all of the beauty you know
seasons she had straight hair she had
the curls the corkscrew curls I like
nerdy Mona personally she was my
favorite I just thought she was so cute
with the little pigtails and the
sweaters and the glasses um yeah I don't
know I kind of I kind of like I said I
kinda liked that she's been through it
all
[Music]